thanks Sara now once again everything
I'll be doing in this lesson I can do
completely offline I won't need internet
access to create a repository or add
commits to it that's why I'm here at the
forest again
first I'm going to create a git
repository I can either do this in an
empty directory and create files later
or I can create the repository in a
directory that already contains files
right now I'm going to use an existing
directory with some recipes
I'll run LS - a and I can see that there
are three recipes here a cake recipe a
frosting recipe and a chili recipe
notice that there isn't a dot git
directory because this isn't a git
repository yet now I'll run git init
which initializes or creates a new git
repository now if I run LS - a again I
can see that the docket directory has
been created
how many commits do you think the new
git repository contains enter your
answer in this box and recall that a
commit is a snapshot of a git repository
if you're not sure how many commits it
will contain then just pick a number you
think is reasonable next what command
could you use to find out the answer to
the previous question here's a hint
this is a git commands that you learned
last lesson